All right,
let's start from the beginning.
With this action,
we edit and save a README.
This change will only affect
the working directory.
All right, what about this one,
git add README?
This will take the change from
the working directory and
add it to the staging area.
So, the staging area will be changed.
Then we have git commit.
Running git commit will create a commit
with the changes from the staging area
and update the master branch.
Okay.
So, what about git pull origin master?
This will take the commit currently
in the master branch on GitHub and
pull it into the local branch and merge
it into what's currently on master.
So, the local master is
the only thing that changes.
Now we have git push origin master.
This will take what's in the local
version and push it to the remote.
So this operation just
changes the remote.
Okay, down to the last one.
If we have a pull request to merge
the alt branch into master, and
that pull request gets accepted and
merged in,
then the alt branch will
get merged with master.
So the GitHub master branch is
the only thing that will get updated.